on est très heureux alors elles sont
trois ce soir les l5 sont avec nous ce
soir toutes les femmes de ta vie on se
rappelle de drew et julie et ya les deux
nouvelles du groupe
voilà malheureusement coralie n'a pas pu
être avec nous ce soir on la retrouvera
dans la tournée back to basic mais
regardez
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
chose je ne s'est pas privé
ce que je propose
oui
tellement que l'état
à voir
est ce que tu as
de taille
[Musique]
ramé
samedi
c'est fait
le temps
[Musique]
ils n'étaient pas
je suis pas
tu vois
je sais que tu vas
je ne faisais même pas peur
[Musique]
c'est tout
si jeune
[Musique]
comment
pas seulement
visa
ce que tu as
oui
[Musique]
ans
attendez j'ai
mais
récit
[Musique]
c
et notre santé
du côté du grand public
[Applaudissements]
ce jour là
[Musique]
toi
on
[Musique]
tg
à table
oui
[Musique]
tg
m
[Musique]
je suis content
tu vois tout
[Musique]
lui
le départ
je suis content pas
tu
[Applaudissements]